les premiers sous monde cherbourg sont
arrivés à maturité depuis une semaine
l'abattage a repris dans la grande rade
près de huit mille poissons ont déjà été
prélevés avant les fêtes de fin d'année
la demande augmente et les clients sont
plus exigeantes
par rapport aux années précédentes le
made in france
le local c'est vraiment quelque chose
que les gens recherchent
il a même l'a récemment des gens qui
débarquent dans la société vont dire moi
je vais acheter votre nom alors que vont
pas encore aux particuliers c'est prévu
mais c'est pas encore et ça c'est
nouveau s ils recherchent vraiment un
produit de qualité
vers en local il faut dire que la
conjoncture est favorable aux
entreprises françaises au chili une
micro ali a décimé plus de 200 mille
tonnes de saumon et la semaine dernière
60 millions de consommateurs révélait
que le saumon biologique pouvait être
fortement toxique
résultat pour la première fois on a eu
des demandes qui sont venus du monde
entier
et ça c'est la première fois qu'on a
effectivement des clients internationaux
qui s'adressent à nous et pour des
volumes pas l'important on a eu des
russes des chinois des américains du
nord des anglais mais comment sont venus
du monde entier
et ça c'est très nouveau ici à cherbourg
donc c'est plutôt rassurantes rassurant
pour les saumons france qui
s'agrandissent encore ils viennent de
faire l'acquisition d'une fumery pour
élargir leur gamme
et pour ces fêtes de fin d'année nous
devons livrer 30 tonnes de saumon